>>Cameron Brown: All right,
your thirty seconds...
Begins right now.
>>Student: Let's confess the U.S. is
a mess, we are a mess, our country,
one of the richest and most
successful in the world,
isn't even on the top twenty
list of healthiest countries.
>>Student: Our TED Talk is about the
fact that our country needs to step
up their game and improve themselves,
if we exercise or eat healthier,
our country can bring themselves
up to the very top of the list.
>>Cameron Brown: One of the
great things about using missions
to teach is that students really
get hooked right from the start,
something that we try to make
really relatable to them.
I mean it's something that
they can be excited about.
For example, with my TED mission
that we're working on right now,
it's giving students a voice to
give their opinion and I think
at this age it's so important
for students to really think
about what they believe
in and start to share
that with people around them.
>>Student: I think
really the nice part
about this was we were only
given a general subject.
We got to pick what we
wanted to do inside it
and I think that's the really
best way to engage children,
is to make sure they get
to have their own input.
'Cause if they don't feel
like they're having an input,
they're not really interested.
>>Cameron Brown: To me, my favorite
part about the Quest model is
that it's so grounded in
skills and real-world topics
that students are interested in.
Using a mission throughout
a trimester is a great way
to not have me stand at the front
of the classroom and say, you know,
"Today we're gonna talk
about the food pyramid."
Okay, and we go through
the food groups,
we talk about each food group,
and there's really no context
for students to what that
really means to them.
To them it's-- you know, I find in
a traditional model that's something
that they would just look at on a
screen, they would take their notes
on it and then they would move on.
But integrating the learning into
a mission model that we have here
at Quest is so important
because we find ways to relate it
to the students in
their everyday life.
>>One of the unique aspects
of hosting this TEDx event is
that the students, they
really take ownership of it.
Okay? So at the start of the
trimester when we start to talk
about possible topics and ideas
that they could present about,
I don't stand up at the front
of the classroom and say,
"Here's a list of five things.
You're gonna select one and
you're gonna present on it."
We work through a series of
lessons where students start
to identify interests and
passions that they have
that would be related
to fueling their body.
>>The presentations are gonna
start in a couple minutes from now?
So from this point forward I want
you guys to be quiet, Michelle,
I want you guys to
be quiet and thinking
about what you're gonna
be saying tonight in your
presentations.
You guys put in a lot of hard work
and now this is the pay off, okay?
So, David, Caleb, let's
do well tonight,
you guys are gonna do a good job,
so remain in your seats, please.
>>Within this model as a
teacher it challenges you
to be a learner as well.
In a traditional classroom, you
know, you can stand at the front
with you textbook and this
is what you have to teach.
But within the Quest
model there's so many
moving parts and things that are
changing and things you have to adapt
to and as someone that's
passionate about that, you know,
we love to get better
at what we're doing.
So I think that that really
piques a teacher's interest.
>>And for the second year in the
"Wellness" domain we are excited
to be hosting TEDxQuestSchool.
>>Student: I'll admit:
Games are addicting.
So what I believe we should
do is cut down slowly.
[laughter] You might want to cut five
or ten minutes a day so you don't,
like, come off it too quickly.
[ laughter ]
>>Student: And then this,
like, meat is, like, all gross.
[ laughter ]
>>Student: I have a plan to fix
this, I call it the "Ten-mile Plan,"
you run at least ten miles
every week and that can be split
up into a running, biking, or
swimming. Oy, so I know
what you're thinking,
"I don't have enough
time to run ten miles."
Raise your hand if you
have a TV, who has a TV?
Raise your hand, oy, so if you
don't have time and you have a TV,
then you obviously do have time
to run, like, two miles a day.
>>Student: I hope we all fight
for our hope and get help.
[ applause ]
>>Student: It was exciting to present
your work to a group of people
that you've never really
known before,
but it was nerve-wracking 'cause you
didn't know what they were gonna say
or react.
>>Student: We were really
nervous before and, like,
while we were presenting.
Like, we were giggling a
bit, but it was really good.
Like, all the attention was on us.
>>Cameron Brown: To me, the most
interesting part of this trimester
and this mission is when
the students find that topic
that they're interested in and then
they see this TED platform for them
to voice their ideas on it.
And when they get that idea and
they're like, "Wow, this is cool
and I'm sharing it with the world."
You know, I was looking on
the TED website yesterday
and they're approaching their
one-billionth view of their talks.
So this is a massive
platform and I think
when the students find what it is
and they start working towards being
on this website, it's
an amazing thing.